and for George I know you don't directly
are involved with the goings-on with the
show right now but I just wanted to get
your opinion on exactly how the show is
deviated from your own writings and how
well you think that should continue or
not continue I always think a Tyrians
nose area nose was a good example I mean
yeah they didn't cut off his nose I
write that you know
yes and they cut off his nose and then I
can make references in the subsequent
books to him having a nose or having a
big scar and to Howard itches and he
scratches it that's relatively easy for
me to do
actually cutting off Peter Dinklage's
nose
was prohibited by the Actors Guild so we
were stuck with well if we wanted to do
that we would have to essentially put a
piece of green screen a little green
kind of thing on the end of his nose
that he would have to wear and all of
his scenes and then we could CGI every
moment he appeared you know the the nose
scar and I was just way too expensive
and it's the practicalities of of doing
it again you know a lot of the changes
that occur between a movie or television
show or book are dictated by practical
considerations like that questions a
budget and shooting time and what can be
done and what what can't be done and I'm
already forgetting the other question
I'm sorry my mind is a sieve here
whenever you if you do hit bumps in the
road or roadblocks with character pots
or like traits or whatever how much of
that do you draw from your personal life
in order to create a more in-depth
character or scene or a relationship a
Song of Ice and Fire is very very long
well it's a fairly long running series
of very long novels and people who read
these who have been reading these novels
since the beginning of developed a kind
of a feel I feel they must have
developed a serious
a feeling of trust that you're going to
be leading them to somewhere that
ultimately has very good payoff do you
feel that with the immense number of
people you kill per book that you could
violate that trust so those go together
you know in terms of the person your
personal experiences and then also the
personal feelings of the readers so well
I hope I don't violate that trust but
you know I've kind of become accustomed
to the fact that some people probably
will think I have but time we reached
the end you know it's it's a it's a
phenomenon of a long series like this
when you know people start noticing it
with the first book or the second book
or the third book and then then they
love those books and the fourth books
not out yet and they start anticipating
the fourth book and they've this
Platonic ideal of what that fourth book
is gonna be develops in their head and
then they get the actual fourth book and
many people are happy with it but then
there's always gonna be a percentage
readers are not happy with it because it
didn't go to way they thought it was
gonna go where it wasn't as as whatever
it was they thought it was so you
inevitably come come on that with a
series but I certainly want to try to
stick the ending as as best I can
it's not easy I mean I'm not gonna name
names here but well we're dinner we were
discussing some other writers and and
you know some very very good writers
have a real problem with endings endings
can be can be tough you know especially
for big sprawling things you pull out a
lot of stuff that's for the question
about yes you do drawn your personal
experience to make characters come alive
to just some extent that's that's where
the inner life comes from that way
that's where the human heart and
conflict itself comes from I was very
threatened as a kid when I knew I wanted
to be writer by the stuff you always
read in like how to write books and
things like only write about what you
know because I wanted to write science
fiction of fantasy and I didn't really
know about being a prince or an
astronaut or you know I was this kid
from New Jersey and we we were poor we
didn't own a car I I'd my my world was
five blocks long and I've seen oh god do
I have to write about a guy who lives in
Bayonne and the projects and walks to
school every day five blocks long but
what I discovered is that what you know
it's not the mundane details of you know
where you live and and what it is but
it's it's what you know is about life
about love but about heroism and
cowardice and and these issues what it's
like to be human and and you have to you
have to draw on yourself to do that yeah
you draw on other things too you read
you read you know characters from
history and you read people in the news
and you have friends and relatives and
guys guys you went to school with and
rose you went to school with and you can
base characters and all of them to some
extent at least externally but you only
know those people unless you're a
telepath and you don't look like a
telepath to me you you don't really know
what's going beyond the behind these
these masks the only one you really know
was yourself and you know I think to be
a significant writer there's a you have
to be willing to kind of expose yourself
and and dig dig deep and you know my
desk Harlan I wasn't worse a bleed on
the paper or something like that and
that's a lesson I learned early on this
that stood me in in good stead I read a
lot about a lot of characters and none
of them are kids from Bayonne
so obviously I'm not writing about what
I know in that sense I I've never been
an exiled princess I've never been a
eight-year-old girl I've never been a
dwarf but there's a lot of me and all
those characters I mean it's well you
know I think what would what would it be
like if I was in a
Berlin Aria situation what would be like
if I was if I was Daenerys Targaryen or
Tyrion Lannister how would it feel and I
do put a lot of myself into that before
I asked my question mr. Martin I really
like to thank you for writing the books
they've had a huge impact on my life um
so thank you my question is how do you
think that the success of the entire
Song of Ice and Fire universe has
influenced the way that you're writing
the future books okay hi I have two
questions the first one's really quick
first what are your favorite house words
and then also I assume you quickly
developed a final outcome for the story
after originally creating it but at some
points you also made changes like the
inclusion of like a five year gap so I
was wondering if there were any other
major deviations or a character choices
that you made and later thought better
of my favorite house words are
definitely winter is coming that's the
1i I write you know repeatedly when I'm
when I used to do inscriptions on sign
books I haven't actually gotten to the
end yet so I don't know if there are
gonna be other major changes it's it's
possible but I don't I think the broad
outlines are gonna remain the same you
know I know where some of the major
characters are going how they're going
to end up how it's gonna resolve but
there are the devil is in the details
and there's a lot of stuff that occurs
when you're actually writing the books I
don't know you you dealt with some of
this some you and Harriet with with
Jordan and I'm sure Jim always said that
he knew the last scene when he when he
started so did did he entrust that to
Harriet and did Brandon write the last
scene that that Jim had originally
envisioned it yeah and that was like 20
years later right what our years later
but of course then he was thinking it
was going to be a trilogy
yeah I'm sorry I'm worried forgetting
the first book I keep forgetting there's
two questions at a time I I'm old and
people so how do you think the success
of the entire universe has influenced
the way that you write the future novels
I don't think it's influenced the way I
read the future novels but it's it's
certainly been a distraction I probably
would have written an almost faster if I
wasn't like always approving things or
going on tours or you know doing humming
the brown doing other coming to brown
yeah to do that I mean this just it's
just a lot of other things and you know
some of it is is good stuff it's stuff I
enjoy enjoy doing I know there's a
subset of my fans so but they could just
chained me to the typewriter and if no
one was giving me awards or in offering
me free trips to to Dubai and and South
Africa and you know maybe I would do
that but when I actually settle down and
write you know between these trips here
and I am trying to guess where I'm
trying to cut down on all of this but
when I'm actually there writing it it's
it's like time vanishes and I'm back I'm
back once again in in Westeros and the
real world disappears and days and weeks
go by and I don't do anything else
except live and breathe those characters
and it's that's still pretty much the
same process everything vanishes
including the show as much as I love to
show it's it's different from the books
and so it's the books and the characters
as I interpreted them to take over my
life